it is my view that the deceitful way the
interview was obtained
substantially influenced what my mother
said
the interview was a major contribution
to making my parents relationship worse
and has since hurt countless others
prince william is speaking out following
an
investigation of the bbc's controversial
interview
with his mother princess diana it brings
indescribable sadness to know
that the bbc's failures contributed
significantly
to her fear paranoia and isolation
that i remember from those final years
with her on thursday the duke of
cambridge released a video in reaction
to these details
which shed new light on diana's rare
interview
over 25 years ago it effectively
established a false narrative
which for over a quarter of a century
has been commercialized by the bbc
and others she was failed not just by a
rogue reporter
but by leaders at the bbc who looked the
other way
rather than asking the tough questions
the investigation determined that
journalist martin beshear lied several
times
to the bbc princess diana and her
brother charles spencer which
then led to the 1995 broadcast that
instantly made headlines around the
world it is welcome that the bbc accepts
lord dyson's findings in full
which are extremely concerning that bbc
employees
lied and used fake documents to obtain
the interview with my mother
made lurid and false claims about the
royal family which played on her fears
and fueled paranoia
displayed woeful incompetence when
investigating complaints
and concerns about the program now the
bbc is saying
the network fell short of high standards
of integrity and transparency
but what saddens me most is that if the
bbc had properly investigated the
complaints
and concerns first raised in 1995
my mother would have known that she had
been deceived
this settled narrative now needs to be
addressed by the bbc
and anyone else who has written or
intends to write about these events
prince harry also reacted to the news on
thursday
the duke of sussex said in a statement
our mother was an incredible woman
who dedicated her life to service she
was resilient
brave and unquestionably honest the
ripple effect of a culture of
exploitation and unethical practices
ultimately took her life
he added yet what deeply concerns me
is that practices like these and even
worse are still
widespread today in an era of fake news
public service broadcasting and a free
press
have never been more important these
failings
identified by investigative journalists
not only let my mother down
and my family down they let the public
down too
william went on to suggest the interview
should lose all
credibility moving forward it is my firm
view that this panorama program
holds no legitimacy and should never be
out again